and you see
i've never understood national pride
i've never understood ethnic pride
because uh i'm irish and i'm all four of
my grandparents were born in ireland so
i'm fully irish
and when i was a kid i would go to the
st patrick's day parade and i noticed
that they sold a button that said proud
to be irish and i could never understand
that because i knew
that on columbus day they sold a
different button that said proud to be
italian then came black pride and puerto
rican pride and i could never understand
ethnic
or national pride because to me pride
should be reserved for something you
achieve
or attain on your own not something that
happens by accident of birth
being irish
being irish isn't a skill
it's a [ __ ] genetic accident
you wouldn't say i'm proud to be 511.
i'm proud to have a predisposition for
colon cancer
so why the [ __ ] would you be proud to be
irish you're proud to be italian or
american or anything
if you're happy with it that's fine do
that put that on your car happy to be an
american
be happy don't be proud too much pride
as it is pride goeth before a fall
never forget proverbs okay now here's
another slogan
here's another slogan you run into all
the time god bless america
once again respectfully i say to myself
what the [ __ ] does that mean
god bless america is that a request
is that a demand is that a suggestion
politicians say it at the end of every
speech
as if it was some sort of verbal tick
that they can't get rid of
god bless you and god bless america god
bless you and god bless america
i guess they figure if they leave it out
someone's going to think they're bad
americans
let me tell you a little secret about
god folks god does not give a flying
[ __ ] about america okay he doesn't care
he never cared about this country
he never has he never will he doesn't
care about this country
any more than he cares about mongolia
transylvania pittsburgh the suez canal
of the north pole
he simply doesn't care okay he doesn't
care
listen hey there are 200 countries in
the world now do these people honestly
think that god is sitting around picking
out his favorites
why would he do that why would god have
a favorite country
and why would it be america out of all
the countries because we have the most
money
because he likes our national anthem
maybe it's because he heard we have
18 delicious flavors of classic
rice-a-roni
it's delusional thinking it's delusional
thinking and americans are not alone
with these sort of delusions
military cemeteries around the world are
packed
with brainwashed dead soldiers who were
convinced
god was on their side america prays for
god to destroy our enemies our enemies
pray for god to destroy us
somebody's going to be disappointed
somebody's wasting their [ __ ] time
could it be
everyone now
now i was over in australia
are you proud to be an american i was
like oh i don't know i didn't have a lot
to do with it you know
my parents [ __ ] there that's about all
you know i was in the spirit realm at
that time [ __ ] parish
[ __ ] paris but they couldn't hear me
because i didn't have a mouth
a spirit without lungs or mouth or vocal
cords
they [ __ ] here okay i'm proud
i hate patriotism i can't stand it man
it makes me [ __ ] sick it's around the
world last time i
checked okay you know what i mean i hate
patriotism in fact
that's how we can stop patriotism i
think instead of putting
stars and stripes on our flags we should
put pictures of our parents
[ __ ] gather people around that flag
and see your dad hunched over your mom's
big four by four butt
see if any boom rally mentality can
circle around that little [ __ ]
image god damn i'm out of here [ __ ] it
get your mom shut up
nationalism does nothing but teach you
how to
hate people that you never met and
all of a sudden you take pride in
accomplishments you had no part in
whatsoever and you brag about
yo like the americans go [ __ ] the french
[ __ ] the french if we hadn't saved their
ass in two world wars they'd be speaking
german right now
you go oh was that us that was us
was that me and you tommy we saved the
french jesus
i know i blacked out a little bit after
that fourth shot of jaegermeister last
night but
i don't remember i know we went through
the wendy's drive-through we're gonna
get one of the fresh set of sandwiches
it looks so alluring on the commercial
but then we ordered it and realized we
had no money and we had to ditch out
before the second window
and those douchebags in line behind us
with the base music probably got our
order now we laughed about that but i
don't remember saving the french
boy i went through the last 10
calls on my cell phone and there's
nothing incoming or
outgoing to the french looking for
muscle on a project
i check my pants there's no mud stains
on the knees from where we were
garaging crouch in the trenches at
berdon
i think we didn't do anything but watch
sports bloopers while we got
hammered i think we should shut the [ __ ]
up
you